like I really felt like this is the
first book I've read since you know the
one that everybody had to read grown up
Catcher in the Rye this is like Catcher
in the Rye uh on mushrooms is the only
way for me to describe it but I actually
like this character where I didn't like
the character oh yeah because he was
kind of a hipster douche like when he
like when he went when he went to go see
that he went he snuck out he goes down
to the village and he goes to see that
piano player right and he says uh
he goes look and the guy was real he was
great at piano and he goes but he knew
he was great oh so that ruined it and
it's just like now he was great at it he
was confident and you knew he was going
to get a bunch of [__] after it and you
weren't so that bothered you and rather
you trying to tap into your own Burt
Reynolds you're gonna resent this guy